okay welcome everybody we are live
streaming now
um
this Workshop I just want to start with
the apologies we've got Alex Tom and
Trish is just going to be a minor
apology for having to go away briefly
um this Workshop will be live streamed
in accordance with the principles of
open and transparent decision making it
has accepted that counselors will have
their own views on many manners
and in many cases might already have
views on what the right answer to an
issue is you're not required to approach
every decision as though you have given
it no prior thought or have no existing
knowledge or opinion however you are
required to keep an open mind and you
must be prepared to change or adjust
your views
in the evidence or arguments if the
evidence or arguments warranted
okay I'm going to pass over to Rihanna
now and she's going to
start proceedings
so this is the first of our activity
workshops now as we move into the
finalization stage for the ltp
um so this workshop's really an
opportunity to hear from the roding
solid waste property and passenger
transport activities this morning we
will reschedule
um regulatory services so for a later
day
um as you're listening to the
presentation that the managers give you
be considering
um what questions that you might have in
terms of areas of change that they're
proposing they will be running through
areas where they recommend changes
required as a result of regulatory or
compliance requirements changing as well
as options that you've already asked
them to bring forward for your
consideration and other areas where they
feel that their change may be required
I'll just remind you that there are
notes in your resource center based on
the community feedback that we've had
through the pre-engagement so these have
been
kind of divided up by activity to make
it easier for you to reference some of
the things that were raised during that
Community engagement of course that's
not a completely scientific process
there's many comments go across
different activities but hopefully
that's a useful resource for you and
just one final point to note obviously
this is early in the activity and asset
planning stage so the numbers that
officers will be presenting are still a
guide at this point so as we move closer
towards budgeting finalization at the
end of the year those numbers will firm
up so it's important to be aware both
for counselors and those watching live
stream that this is very much a work in
progress that's the point of these
workshops
so on that note I think I think chair
we're ready for the discussion of the
writing act okay and note the timetable
is slightly adjusted now to the previous
council meeting so welcome Leslie and
Russell
Kiera good morning councilors and me and
Obi
that says the writing presentation for
our asset planning process Leslie has
been working pretty hard on this and
we'll be doing most of the presentation
so yes
um one of the things that we see is that
our works are reasonably um well
connected to wakugatahi um and our
subsidy so we're running I guess a
couple of processes one we're trying to
explain where we think this will go but
we've also got another process where we
also need to bid inside their inside
there I guess
um process as well so
um this is really an opportunity for us
to bring back those ideas bringing up
speed with where our thinking is and
certainly towards the end of the
presentation we've got some ideas and
yes Direction which we will be happy to
get some feedback on on the way past so
over to Leslie
Cura council's marinavi um so the
overview of our activity is our primary
reason for being is to for safe and
connected and accessible transport
system for our city
um so we look after the Rhodes footpaths
street lights traffic signals
um
Bridges and other structures and any
drainage within the road corridors and
we also look after complete Network
planning and um any capital projects to
do with safety and
um and encouraging active transport and
reducing carbon emissions through our
activity
and we work closely with um SDC and GDC
on a road safety cycling platform
and we we tie really closely with them
on this and we also work fairly closely
with kotahi nzta
um environment Southland especially on
the Strategic transport planning piece
so from a national context we have a new
Minister David Parker in the Ministry of
Transport and
um we bid through this land transport
GPS for Budget through the national land
transport program
um the national learn transport fund is
allocated through the GPS
um
so they also control other funding
potential like the Cerf fund being the
climate emergency fund and provide
direction for crown on funding
um so this is a
the ltp also aligns with the nltp and we
put our funding through for wakakotahi
for a three to ten year period also
through this process and
prior to cyclone Gabrielle focus of the
GPS was um
guided towards the reduction of
emissions and that was going to be their
focus and their core consideration for
all decisions but since um Cyclone
Gabrielle they've put a pause on the GPS
and they have mildly indicated that
there be a greater focus on
reconstruction of damaged infrastructure
and building back better resilience
so
then if we come down one level to a
strategic context our attacking hiku
it's Baka kotahi's Regional direction
for muriheku Southland and this was re
um
redeveloped in 20 March 2023 and um what
they're saying up there is that we've
got good capacity in our existing
Network and
um there's opportunities within our
transport system to increase rail
Freight
um
opportunities
but we have a very high high Reliance in
Southland on private vehicles and we
have below average participation in
walking and cycling and they're they're
encouraging us to move into active modes
of transport and the prime and our
primary goal for these guys is to reduce
Vehicle Club I'm sure it's traveled
within our Network to reduce help reduce
carbon emissions
um part of our network is susceptible to
flooding and erosion but this is
probably more indicative on the
wakakotahi network within our region and
Bluff Highway being one place of the
network that is successful to these
threats
um
so focus on a low-carbon economy are
inter-regional connections with SDC GDC
and our ability to improve road safety
and
reduce pollution pollutants sorry
um moving to a multimodal Freight System
moving away from road towards Rail and
implementing Road Safety plans and
programs there's a real Focus for
arataki Mir Hoku
our local context is that we have a
large number of fatalities on our
Network in comparison to others and that
we have modal conflict in our Network
um being right cycling private use
Vehicles we have increasing customer
expectations and we have
increasing expectations from our funders
on
um proving
investment decisions Etc so I guess I
might just pause was we've thrown lots
of acronyms at you on the way past
um so we're happy to either gather some
questions up at the end or if there is
something you wanted to talk but at
least he's just ran I guess through the
Strategic piece how we link our Council
to
wakatai in the funding so it's really us
trying to merge the government's
priorities and the council's priorities
together to get that funding
yeah
yeah so just interested in the
particular reference to rail
has there been any feedback sought from
industry around the logistics of
actually enacting there and the cost
related to that because it might be a
fairy tale idea that we want to put more
freight on rail
but the reality is because of the way a
routing system and our system works
around how we logistically move Goods
around our country
the best way forward as Road and then if
you look at the development so I'm not
sure that you're weird but there's a
fonterra truck that's traveling every
day from
um Edendale to Candy Boy killed by
hydrogen
so you know that that space is moving
very very rapidly so I challenge The
View that there's going to be more
freight and more use of non-roading
services and how that might drive a
decision really concerns me and the
other point I'd point to I know that the
railway line between here and Ohio was
30 million dollars was spent and to my
knowledge the only thing that goes down
there is coal and we reference a carbon
neutral environment so you know our
ideology and our reality around
investment seem very confused at a
national level
Mr chair yes there's a couple of things
there that what we do know is that kiwi
around now have to seek funding from the
national land transport program which is
and I guess it's funded nationally there
are South Island Freight studies to try
to identify where the freight
opportunities are and kiwi kiwi rail are
invited to the regional transport
committees to actually be able to
participate at that Regional level I
understand what you're saying is there
are competing challenges at a on a
national level but I guess that's the
messaging that we should continue to
feed into the GPS when it comes out for
public
or for councils and product as well so
sorry secondly just so here's unders
through being Consultants so the main
phrase can be a large transport things
that aren't kiwi rail have they've been
had active input into developing the
strategies yes there is a national there
is a South Island Freight study that's
been undertaken that has actually hit
cons consulted with the big tracking
firms
Coastal shipping be infected and Coastal
shipping is one of those I guess the
port is part of the I guess that at that
strategic level that's actually I guess
the domain of the Regional Council to
actually manage the Strategic level
across the whole Province but yes it's
one of those I guess another area that
we see is potentially going forward as a
um as potential but we don't necessarily
influence it too much but it's how we
access Goods to and from our from our
community which is I guess our biggest
challenge
uh Barry then Evelyn yeah can you give
us some some sort of update on the road
between invercargill and Bluff with the
low lowing areas of it
it's a good question but a difficult one
um my understand it's a it's a road
that's managed by katahi so
um I have um heard at a recent meeting
where there has been a bid put forward
by the
um team at wakatai across the whole
country for funding for doing some
resilience works and my understanding is
that's on that program but whether or
not that's been been awarded to um that
right or not so I haven't got a
definitive answer but I know they've
highlighted sections of the road as
being relatively low-lying and are
looking to make some improvements but
I'm unsure whether that's been funded
but that's not necessarily Council
funding that's Government funding
it's always in the same places so like
literally we're
the robot yeah that's right Evelyn
um so I'm glad somebody else asked about
Coastal shipping
um I see that as part of the um
energy resilience and and climate change
is that they are actually promoting
um more use of C transport for Gods does
that therefore the corollary of that is
is that more containers therefore more
need for rail or are we going to see
more containers go on the back of trucks
because that's for me is
perhaps not necessarily A
forward-looking Move however
um seriously Russell do you have a um
some sort of indicator of what that
means I think I think the um the
challenge that we have is how do we
actually manage with the increased
Freight movements going forward
um given that we've got some Greenhouse
emissions type targets to meet and some
are in there is actually the use of all
of these things how do we actually use
different fuels how do we use different
modes but I guess that's the future
challenge but
that's across all of those things is the
context that we operate and need to
develop our plan for invercargill City
around so I guess we need to say how do
we actually allow for more more of all
of those things and actually tied into
our community so that's just against the
high level strategic but perhaps we
might just carry on and take us where
our plans can be taken part because it's
the safety the safety part
um one of I've expressed this concern
before is the increasing heavy traffic
on the Macquarie Street Scott Street and
how well equipped our community is to
understand that because until I live
down there I don't think I really
understood it either
um then it is not that little Rural Road
that it used to be that it's actually
quite a major uh heavy traffic transport
area and who makes those sorts of
decisions and how much control the city
has over of those
um it's a beautiful segue into the next
section which Lizzy's going to talk
about our Network Frameworks right yeah
look at how roads and how roads I've
done just to keep going because
otherwise Rhiannon will look at me and
get here I'm getting kicked yeah
um so wakakota he used to have
um the O NRC the one network Road
classification and they are moving into
what's now called the one network
framework
so this new framework doesn't just
consider traffic movements but also
considers people in place within the
hierarchy of Roads so it gets um
movement of traffic versus people in
place and how to operate those spaces in
different levels of service for our
community
and
so that we're all speed this is so that
we're all speaking at the same language
when we're going up for bidding for our
um programs
for an example escondon Street would be
considered main streets within this new
one network framework
and perhaps very quickly to answer
Evelyn's question is that Council has
the ability to actually manage its
Network classification for a street it
also has powers under bylaws if it
wishes to restrict access but in
principle
um every vehicle is equal we want some
streets to have different types of
vehicles but once again we've got the
freight movement against the people
movement so there are streets where we
would say
you shouldn't go down there and we
certainly restrict the heavy vehicles
but we do end up with
um some some trucks using specific roads
that perhaps they haven't in the past
because destinations end but we have a
grid Network so we actually have to have
an efficient Network as well to make
sure our communities we are serviced by
those because otherwise the cost of our
Goods will increase if we make it too
difficult
so we're working into the future for the
network planning as Russell just
described and uh this will inform
District plans and long-term plans etc
etc moving forward and be informed can
you buy those can I just jump and
wrestle and ask just for Waka kotahi
funding now
the funding is from
fuel tax road users tax
and that's about it isn't it
um Mr chair it is a hypothecated fund so
every dollar that we put in through fuel
taxes and wages are licensing gets put
into the national poll
um whether that's sufficient to actually
meet the demands of the whole country is
the challenge and certainly the EV
challenge is something that
will I guess be addressed in time as I
think it was that the EVS weren't going
to be charged until they're five percent
of the total vehicles in New Zealand I
guess we might be approaching that so
there will be a change somewhere in the
and I know it's being considered about
how you might
would gain enough Revenue to pay for
roading I suppose is the challenge that
we have yeah just that um since I've
been on Council those roading uh forums
that we go to uh provincially the the
funding hasn't been there for the last
10 years so I'm just wondering when part
of the tax dollar you're you know your
collection by government is going to
actually come back because what I'm
seeing is that the vehicles are spending
more time on the road with their engines
going because it's taking longer to get
somewhere and if they were able to get
there because of lack of congestion you
wouldn't have that problem
it's the Dilemma that we face is how do
we pay for how do we pay for what we
what we want yeah and I guess as we get
through this presentation we've got um a
number of slides at the end where we're
putting up options that you may wish to
consider
um you always have the choice to
um fully pay for it as the community or
you have the option to actually bid as
part of a national land transport
program and get some subsidy on it which
is a good investment however you still
can decide to pay for it fully as
Council there's no reason why you
couldn't if you wish to invest but it
cost you twice as much okay thanks
so just to give an overview of what our
current assets are like in comparison to
the National and our regional Partners
so um these roads have now been divided
up into the new one network framework
categories and our smooth travel
exposure is either consistent or better
than the national average across our
Network
the cargo's green yes sorry
um and our current activity for for Peak
roughness is also either
at the same standard as National or
better for roughness on our road
corridors
um in wakako tahi's eyes we don't
necessarily have a problem with our
roads themselves and but then when you
get to our Collective risk
um it does point to a very different
picture in that we have um
deaths and serious injuries per
kilometer are quite bad on our rural
roads our local streets and our activity
streets so this is a
point of
um focus for us moving forward
um this is also the community of risk
register that's done every year and this
is the latest one in 2022 where
unfortunately we come out worse on all
intersections nationally where our road
controlling Authority so
but that is a focus of our investment
planning moving forward so now being
number one is the worst place to be out
of 67 and it's done from a statistical
basis across New Zealand and uses
standard deviation so when you're
actually in a Red Zone like we are that
showing that we are statistically quite
different from the rest of the country
and is quite a sobering result we've
been in all in sections in some of those
vulnerable and areas being consistently
for unfortunately a reasonably long
period of time
um is being quite We Stand Out
unfortunately from the rest of the
country
so we do have a safety problem in our
community
right uh Ria then Evelyn
um just a couple questions just for the
interest of everyone around this table
what is the cost to us per death per
kilometer
I don't have that on me I'm sorry no
that's okay it's a reasonably big number
my recollection is it's about three to
four million dollars or something I
can't quite remember but that's a
fatality cost I wanted to point that out
because you know this is actually quite
serious the other area like with our
intersection mortalities
we are as a council collectively already
putting aren't we good
um
what would I say measures
[Music]
um
conditions to try and lower that because
we've got our safety program which has
been recognized
we're certainly working as very hard on
actually looking to identify and address
situations
um
one of the things that we do Strikers
that often because it's nationalized you
divide the number of crashes by your
vehicle kilometers traveled so
um Auckland will have a lot more in
number but a lot more kilometers
traveled so I guess it's it's part it's
part of that but it does actually
reflect I guess the way they've done it
is to highlight so you can focus your
programs into those areas and that has
is what we have been and continue to do
it will
um so my question was fairly similar and
Russell is in part answered it it's not
based on population though you're saying
it's based on on amount of kilometers
per year I wonder about the risk of
distortion
um if you're using that sort of modeling
um given that we're a relatively small
population and uh potentially perceived
as low kilometers traveled that one
crash one fatality looks
becomes disproportionately magnified and
I don't mean to belittle the fatality I
mean
one amongst a population of 50 000 is
much greater impact than in the whole
population of Auckland and does it make
it seem worse I don't mean seriously
don't mean to diminish what our
responsibility is or anything else but
can we turn how much waiting do you give
the way these statistics look
Mr T we use this as to read to keep our
mind sharp about
safety is one of our key things that we
do
um
what's not that we don't we we continue
to focus and and look at our
intersections as as areas where our
programs are developed and
um you look to actually solve some of
those a number of air crashes that we
see are relatively random and
um very there's no there's no pattern to
to what we see so sometimes we're
chasing lightning a little bit but it
just continues to remind us that that
you know some of the driver Behavior we
see in and around our community
um the way our Network's set up where we
need to invest is actually really key to
our future
um writing and transport networks going
forward so that's the real message that
we're getting today is that
um safety is is one of the key things
that we have in when we've been looking
at what our big problems are safety is
what it comes out as our number one
the number one problem we need to
continue to ask whenever we invest is it
does it improve our safety
I mean can you just quickly clarify to
me again um air rank so we are the worst
for all of the sections out of how many
67 news 67 councils so we're not 67th
we're not the best at anything sort of
our sort of but average is what you're
saying there no it seems to be a strange
way to do it they've um that's the
number one is the worst it's a wee bit
um yeah because you wouldn't say it's
like cyclists involved with a fifth you
see now are they country you know like
rural sort of
related or Tower related because that
would make a difference too you know
without verges on the sides rural roads
and things I mean this doesn't need to
break down even a little bit further
than that this is a I guess a high level
we have um lots of data about that and
lots of time spent analyzing these these
things specifically both hours and
across other networks
but I guess if I just if you just left
you with that thought that says these
are the these are the vulnerable points
in our community and and Allen's right
the cyclists show that we do have a
disproportionately higher number of
crashes that involve a cyclist for some
reason in our community somewhere with
intersections sorry just sorry Christian
um and same with intersections like I
mean you've got sort of semi-rural
injections and I know one very
particularly bad one that has been had
fatalities yet nothing's been done on
the corner and I know that you guys have
just recently been made aware of it
again
that's the one out at Morris Bush of
course you know now that's another
section of course that
someone is going to die there again soon
um
so you've got all the sections here so
is it 10 under sections or is it the
rural intersections you know because
obviously you know you've got these
Crossroads in the rural community that
we have data and data and data and we
analyze it continuously to look for
Trends and looking for to try to
identify where we might be next I guess
once again I come back to this is redis
highlights this is our focus our focus
is about safety their focus going
forward has to be about moving safety
and addressing those places that we know
of and can improve with
with appropriate time and treatments
nothing
just two quick Reflections um
certainly the over 75s and given up
we've got some counselors heading that
way
um
um I guess one of the factors that kicks
in is that some of the comparisons we
have with other cities have public
transport we don't have so we're older
people might train or a bus and go to
town our elderly are more likely to get
into a car but the issue of interest for
me is a cyclist one because I noticed
that in some of our larger cities
Dunedin Wellington and Auckland in
particular there's been quite a bit of
emphasis on cycle Lanes
um but there's been a lot of angst
around that as well because to make them
safe with cycle Lane safe you've got to
take out the parking it's on the on the
left-hand side
um because I suspect a lot of our cycle
issues are around
um not moving vehicles but people that
Park on that in the site a bike comes
down the outside
rolls the door open
um so quite a complex issue and I I'm
quite pleased from a safety perspective
that we haven't pursued what we were
crawling sometime down in Devon Street
and other places because while it's nice
about the bike through the inner city
there are some horrible risks involved
with it as well unless you really want
to take those car Parks out which means
you've got to force people into car
parking as opposed to
Road time
Grant or do you want to answer that
Russell again
today is really about us talking about
our Ford program of which will include
active transport roads and I guess
that's where the direction our future
direction if we want to be much more
carbon and neutral in the future we'll
have to address some of those active
transport modes in the city and actually
determine how we go forward but
okay I'm gonna
um just for time's sake like we're going
to move on but that is a very
provocative slide and it's always going
to draw questions and to me as chair
I've got to say that that number one out
of 67 for the intersections highlights
why we are so bad at roundabouts why our
drivers don't seem to understand how a
roundabout works so it all makes sense
so um please carry on
yeah the computers decided to
have a wrist
oh well that was a good presentation
yeah look at the cyclist thing just well
we're waiting there we go here we go so
I guess this the slide is really just
talking about the level of investment
that we're currently doing in
um what was what we're suggesting is
that we spend about 8.5 million dollars
in Opex about eight million dollars in
capex
air subsidy rate from wakakata he is and
it will be down to 51 percent it is
um
but in terms of what we're spending
depreciation versus renewal we have a
gap in there that we will eventually
have to continue to watch and manage
over our time frame so that's just
really looks to give you the sort of
order of spend that we have so
um the 51 subsidy means that for every
dollar you for every two dollars you
spend physically on a job you get a
dollar from somebody else so it's a
pretty good it's the best deal out there
so it equally means and I'm going to
pitch my story is that when you start
looking for savings for every two
dollars you have to take off you only
get a dollar value back so
um just gotta remember in that space
that writing's the best investment in
town yeah you're right
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to wait
till we get through the slides and then
we'll do some questions yeah cheers
radio so um our demand I split into
three spaces and it's being uh people in
place so our CBD our future stages in
there the CCTV Urban rejuvenate
Rejuvenation being Bluff South City and
Windsor are all within the next 10-year
time frame 10 12 year time frame and
Bluff and so
um lifting that level of service there
um there's also safety and movement so
um we've just spoken quite a bit about
safety about increasing programs into
our road safety education increasing
well
focusing our funding and investment from
with working with broke zero and
makakotahi on a road safety capital
projects
and uh minor Improvement programs
there's also the demand from the from
the community which you've all heard
about our unsealed Road Network and um
moving into more active modes of
transport
and we also have new compliance
requirements and traffic management is
one of those ones that stepped up into a
new level of a risk-based system and
we're required to show more of our
investment programs to Waka kotaki and
approve our spending with Net Present
Value calculations we've also got a new
project coming up being consistent data
collection throughout the national
program and that will mean that all of
the roads nationally will be tested
under the same
um measures and collect and then the
next project underneath that being the
asset management data standards will
enable wakakotahi to ensure that we're
all bidding with the same data and
consistent that's going to kick off in
the next 18 months and it will be quite
a considerable project for us to get all
of our data into the right process and
systems and then on top of that
obviously climate change and risk and
resilience is now an oversight with with
all investment going forward we also
have our bylaws and policies that we
need to ensure compliance of being the
code of practice and the
New footpath Management policy Etc
um our we also have a challenge to
maintain our current levels of service
with our investment
um levels
excuse me
yep and we're just gonna let Aaron add
to that apologies I should have just
made sure we provided the context at the
beginning of the process this is just a
little bit different to how we've done
this perhaps in previous years in that
what staff are putting forward through
the various different slide packs today
is somewhat more unconstrained than what
we perhaps would have seen it in the
past so previously we would have
essentially run a financial lens over
this around what was affordable this
time we're putting much more forward to
to council and then I guess there would
be there needs to be some good
conversations between elected members
and staff around where the best spend is
given our financial constraints as we
work through the process
so thank you yeah maintaining our
current levels of service so we're just
currently out for our new
um road maintenance contract and that I
will be started on the first of October
um
are obviously indicating there's not
going to be much more money in the
bucket for us so um bitumen course and
contractor availability are
on a tighter budget and um we have no
internal
ESG or internal Consultants anymore so
we are using external Consultants to
provide our engineering Professional
Services
um
then
um improvements to opportunities for
cost savings is to ensure that we're
investing in the right places using the
future network operation framework which
also leans on that onf that we spoke
about at the beginning
um considering reducing the level of
service on some of the surfaces so
moving from asphalt to chip seal or from
uh instead of just chip sealing using
some Rejuvenation seals in that space
um allocating the lane Corridor in a
different
um allocations towards that using
AI technology to develop
um models of how where we can invest in
the right place at the right time rather
than on a life cycle management approach
well it'll be still a life cycle
management approach but just with
condition
layered onto it and
and then we're into
[Applause]
yeah
so what we've developed over the next
couple of slides are are used some of
the options that Aaron has talked about
so we've really put up all of the
options that we think are things that uh
Beyond air in your current renewal
approach which really gives an
opportunity for councilors to see
um
what we think could be things that you
might have an interest in and then as we
get towards the end of this pack
um areas where you might want to make
some choices so this so This slide is
all about the uh the Optics
um so what we're actually suggesting
through here is that these are the
things that are aren't our normal BAU so
we've got things like once we have our
CCTV up and running it will have an
additional cost we've got Stirling point
in the future some option we've got some
additional
um City Center as we do other works how
we actually continue to maintain
that area in a in the state that we wish
for it to be we're suggesting that we
invest some more into road safety
education programs
um we've got under one two one which is
the
the additional effort that we believe
that we will need to make sure that we
can keep the streets we've currently
invested in up to a tidy and appropriate
standard
and some additional costs for some
repairs in that area so that's sort of
the Optics type of things that we can
we've we see as being put on the table
through the budget process and will need
to be considered
so perhaps we'll go to the next one
because the next List's a little bit
longer
so what we've also developed is a range
of
opportunities for Council to consider
where they would like to invest if they
would like to invest
and we've started um this very briefly
the seal extensions which we've heard is
and what we're suggesting is that we
would invest four hundred thousand
dollars over five years which being two
million dollars into creating some seal
extensions if that's what's required by
the community so it's two million
dollars over five years part of that
will be is how would you uh where where
will you do it is I guess a different
question but it's about that level of
investment some of these capital
projects may or may not get um type
subsidies so some of these might be that
full Council costs so
um we have a whole range of I guess
Suite of
um
pieces that you could pick and choose
from where they include the Greenways um
footpaths that we're currently
underfunding further footpath Works was
currently we have we renew rather than
extend our foot path networks there are
opportunities in there to perhaps put
um for either footpath and or street
lights in Toyota Tara if you so chose or
some Dutch improvements at a later stage
and we've got some Works around auditory
school that might be appropriate to
invest in
um the Latin work which is I think
number 50 which is where we try to calm
cars around
um our urban areas because we often get
lots of people ringing saying that it's
too fast how do we slow them down and
the only way we can slow them down is by
investing in some of the things to make
sure that's like at the moment we don't
have a budget allocated for that
um we've got three items in there which
are the refresh of the Suburban areas
remembering we did some work some 20
years ago I'm in Bluff South City and
Windsor and we need to invest in that
area
um
we've got some ongoing we'll end up with
some further CCTV renewal and
replacement and then extensions Sterling
points uh
um more of an options what are we going
to do because we haven't got a magic
solution we've put some numbers about
um
Center stages later stages just as a
suggestion
so I guess that's the sort of things
that we're seeing as the smorgasbord of
options that you might have that you
might want
To Have and Have Some choices over
and a last slide actually gives an
opportunity for you to perhaps give us
some feedback and we can put ticks and
Crosses against some of the some of the
things that you say yes that's a good
idea no it's too too much or we'll go
away we don't want that
okay
um we've got uh just over 10 minutes
until the next topic I'm going to start
with Grant and then Darren Grant you
were you'll be stuck with that question
you had
a few slides ago but I've got another
question
um so just to try and understand what
you put up there Russell so both the
Optics and the capex that's when you
think the timing of that expenditure
will occur
correct these are things that are just
outside our BAU like our normal
resurfacing or Urban Channel programs
these are things that we think are
options that you might want to consider
for your for the long term plan and when
they when they will occur in any
consequential Opex that brings them back
so so the CCTV project in terms of capex
we proved a spend of about a million
dollars I think so
there was an operational expenditure of
100 000 per year for 10 years and
there's a CAPIC expenditure of 200 000
previous years so what I'm trying to
understand is are we going to be 10
years getting a CCTV up absolutely not
but what I'm suggesting is you have CCTV
you're going to have to keep operating
it's not going to so that's the Optics
and then the capex is actually as you
put more in you'll want more yeah and
you might just say we've already got a
million dollars cross across that line
out but I guess I'm putting it up
because as you get more you want more I
can assure you yeah yeah and then second
question sorry is because I didn't get
one before yeah that's right
just here you caused the refresh of
those Suburban areas
have you done that so you know what
you've got Bluff for Bluff happening
year four wins a year six and see I said
a year later I'd love to say it's
alphabetical but it's actually the order
we did them so we did Bluff first and
then we did uh South City and then we
did Windsor and I just randomly
um put them across to space them out
because there is quite a bit of work and
realizing it is a cost but I guess it's
really saying is and these are tens
hundreds of thousands so it's 1.5
million dollars what we're talking about
is to actually address these as
um you know Bluff hasn't had a refresh
since 2006. yeah where it's probably
more the South City one around the
investment that's happening around Grove
Street project and some of those other
things and we talked about at the last
council meeting and
you know be good to see Investments
sooner rather than later and I guess the
opportunity is to bring those forward
but it just shows you what's in that
10-year period because
I'm a realist I don't think you can
afford all of that no
I like to think you were and what's my
two to one investment but most of this
won't be funded from wakotahi I would
imagine but you can't not remember those
are the things that you need to do at
some stage and the challenge you'll face
is what you can afford and which is in
and which is not and that's the that's
the huge challenge that will be faced
through this budget because I guess
you're going to hear three or four
presentations after this one which will
have a reasonably big list of options
and that's what they simply are Darren
just having a look at the kpis that you
were wanting to be measured against I
have a concern around the top one which
is a reduction in the number of fatality
accidents because I think it's
subjective we don't want to wear
the blame in reporting against a kpi of
the majority of fatality accidents might
be say driver era as opposed to
intersection faults that measure is a
measure given to us by the DIA and as a
requirement of us to collect
oh God
I'll stop there I'll apply a handbrake
since we're talking Automotive Mr G I
think there's also an opportunity there
just it's also just a good time to
refresh every year to say how have we
done as a whole whole of community and
um we agree that sometimes we can't
control everything but it is a good
chance to refresh how important safety
should be and is to our community
um and actually keep our focus on that
Barry yeah I had I had a meeting with
Simon uh Valentine yesterday the
community policeman and uh he bought he
brought up a lot of concerns about the
CC TV not working
and uh how do we stop board races like
this is where some of these accidents
are happening they don't care they just
run right through intersections they
just keep on going
is there any why we uh complained to put
speed bumps
in some of their streets to slow these
ones down
and I guess that's worked in in like uh
Philippines for illustrate ones like
that we have and that's I guess part of
it what we call a letter my local area
traffic management but that's actually
you have two things you do is you either
um you move them
which is great we've moved them from but
to do the whole city will be a time
consuming and you've also you've got to
balance the accessibility for the rest
of the people against those people
um it's it's a huge challenge everywhere
and and relative to other cities we have
seemed to have possibly a lesser problem
than other places but it's a it is a it
is an ongoing problem of you know safety
but interestingly the statistics would
suggest that that's not necessarily
where our crashes have been occurring
doesn't mean it's not a problem yeah
just some feedback from Russell around
the three issues that you have there for
odatara look I can't see any what reason
why we would spend money on footpaths
lighting and ditches
um and not everybody you know Tara will
agree with that but people move there
for a semi-rural lifestyle
um there was never any expectation that
a lot of the streets would have would
have lighting I mean duns Road and the
safety corridor you've got there's been
an excellent development
um and so uh and the one issue I think
that's still out stands out there and
you've touched on it is the whole issue
of parking in vehicle access around the
school I mean that's something we need
to continue to work on because it's been
ongoing saw for a while but those are
the three oh I wouldn't go there I'd
rather seating this one at South City
we've got a greater intensive population
base so you get more bang few bucks
let's cheer we've we've put them up as
ideas and therefore that's that's the
opportunity I guess one comment around
Atara School we've placed it in there
um
because we might have to co-invest with
other cool with other people who create
problems
um and I would have a degree of caution
about us having to fix some of those
problems you know one of we have lots of
issues around schools but once we start
we see a really strong direction that we
will be
involved and I haven't necessarily put
lots of numbers beyond that it is
certainly a problem
um it's a problem for the community it's
a problem we need to invest in and find
an access acceptable solution
okay uh Evelyn next
um yeah Russell I looking at the safety
Improvement latm which I assume is the
things like
um the reduction of space around certain
areas in certain streets all that sort
of thing
to Market this to the population
how do we demonstrate that what we're
doing have done to date has made a
difference what
measurements are we taking to assess
that because
um
I live in one of those areas and what I
notice is that some people are really
God and then there's the other people
who know amount of
um
signage or even traffic lights has any
impact on your behavior so to justify
doing more how do we say to people what
we've done is working and we need to do
more of it
um it's a really really good question I
guess part of that is how much resource
do we put into that and that's probably
where we haven't necessarily delivered
fully on post implementation studies and
that's a big challenge but what we do
see is speed reduction in the areas I
know that certainly when Windsor Street
put the bumps and we got a shift in the
speed
people have learned to drive them so
we've got a little bit of an increase
but you're right as you invest into
these areas part of that might be that
we need to actually show that we are
getting the right outcomes what we do
also have as a whole lot we have a
number of intersections where we have
forward programs where we've got some
really interesting
um parking and traffic related issues
that we will need to bring back to
council
um to talk about how we solve problems
and how some very hard decisions might
need to be made
to actually solve these problems and
often more often than not all of our
troubles around fixing things are around
parking
so the short answer to your question is
yes we need to do more to demonstrate
because not everybody likes the
the the way they drove somewhere cut off
by Council and the sorts of things that
we would talk about in some of our busy
roads having lift and left out so you
wouldn't be able to go straight through
or you wouldn't be able to turn
um where are the crashes what are the
crashes caused by so we would force
people to use our road hierarchy to
actually travel on roads where we want
them to be on in a trip it means we
would in control that's what the network
operating framework does we've got busy
busy roads we would make sure people
would have to travel on that not on that
grid Network and that won't necessarily
to be fair be the most popular decisions
for a period of time
right two last questions Grant and then
the mayor and that's the end of the
section thanks so just um Sterling Point
we were down there a while ago with the
black community and it needs some work
so it'd be good to see it brought up the
curve in terms of investment and
secondly how do we analyze the
investment
so how are we actually monitoring that
every dollar I've spent
in any of these areas back roading or
some of the simple structure is actually
getting as much of a dollar return
are we doing any analysis around that
and where we can make some changes
because it's always
generally a bit more
asking for more money not necessarily
about looking and seeing if we can be
more efficient around how every dollar
is spent and the classic on point was
Road Safety uh sorry is health and
safety managing on the roads the
information I've received is at up to 40
cents in every dollar and spent on the
roads is related to health and safety
and so if you get more effective and
efficient around hell health and safety
is undertaken you could get a 20
increase without spending any more money
it's a really good question I know under
our renewals program which isn't
necessarily these um we have to do what
they describe as Net Present Value type
calculations so we can't repair a road
until such time as we've actually done
enough maintenance over a period of time
so it sounds like a strange thing to say
but sometimes we have to maintain it let
it go and then repair it we also know
that cost benefit ratios are used on
safety improvements so often if you have
crashes then you have the cost of
crashes uh benefit by reduction so
that's why some some of the bigger
projects generate it but some of these
are really difficult because some of
them have got community Goodwill and
and you you are a number of there are a
number of factors you can apply when you
do certain things in letters because you
know that if you don't have straight
through or right hand crashes you don't
have those so you can have a reduction
in your potential to cause crashes but
it's it's a challenge in some of these
areas to actually do a pure business
case and cost benefit ratio on some of
them investment
distribution
Russell just around the issue of a
closure of S3 and that you and I have
talked about this but um it just seems
to be an ongoing concern that um
as we're trying to enliven our CBD and
get more activities in in the history in
particular at night time when we have
some listening with the flame throwers
or whatever they were
um we had to get a traffic management
system to come in and
um I guess manage the street that was
already close the bollards that we just
push up anyway
um two and a half thousand dollars for
about three or four hours
um it just it just takes away the
incentive for other groups that might
want to do an activity in there that
have that cost as well so whether some
way internally that we can um
help keep the cost down or have internal
resources that we can use as opposed to
Contracting media it just seems prohibit
of small groups wanting to do things
Russell do you want to come into that
um given the time I'm I'm happy to
perhaps bring a paper to council because
I think we've indicated that somewhere
through the life of V street we will
need to revisit how we use this street I
guess in simple terms I think the cost
of doing traffic management for the uh
night closure was actually 600 of actual
I guess hiring equipment in a plan
um a big chunk of the time was actually
having resources on site
um from from the company to manage the
site
um use it to cost
um but if something goes wrong we have
to still follow our legislative thing it
is a road and the road has a purpose if
you want to stop it for an event you
have to have a travel management plan
and but if we can reduce the cost
um we're all for that we're not
necessarily trying to put a barrier up
so
thanks uh Leslie and Russell but before
we close this one off Rhiannon has asked
me to ask
um this
to ask you all if you can pick your top
three from that list of
options for Council to consider and
email them through to Rhiannon by the
end of the week be fantastic just pick
three
yeah
Russell do you want to speak to this
slide and give some different
instructions I'm just thinking it's
probably best done offline now it's we
can do it offline I've in the last
couple of slides always stood is
actually put a box there and you could
um we can certainly circulate that so
you can give some suggestion about where
your direction would be because we'll
need that to incorporate it so you're
going to send that out to everyone
awesome
had a refresh for many years in the road
and because we have so many tracks that
come in and out suspicious to our Port
you know there there is sort of some
need or attention around that as well as
the steering point
so yeah two separate things but I'm
wondering how we can connect certainly
our proposal is about Street and people
space yeah
yeah thank you Russell do you want to
swap seats or stay there
I see you in the next one are you
not
we have Solid Waste
that's Russell
and Annie no no Evelyn uh Aaron
so this is going to primarily be Annie's
presentation
um and I guess I'll just be here in case
we get any early discussion
I've got quite a few slides here so I
think we'll go through all its lines and
then save the questions to the end
thanks Kiara everyone
gorgeous
beautiful
I'll be going through these nine items
and the slides to follow
activity type waste portfolio has two
types of activity waste net activity and
ICC only activity waste net activities
include rubbish collection rubbish
disposal and the education and
communication delivery
invercargill city council only
activities include solid-based
activities which are transfer station
services and Recycling services and
other activities around the closed
landfill
I'll be talking about the different
contract numbers mentioned here in the
contracts update slide
next slide new legislation changes new
legislation changes were announced on
29th March 2023 and these legislation
changes have provided councils with a
timeline to improve curbside services to
minimize the waste into landfill the
changes are number one standard
standardized acceptable recyclables by
2024 this essentially means making
materials collected from households for
recycling the same across altaroa from
the figure on the right hand side shows
what will be accepted in our yellow bin
starting February 2024. number two
residential curbside recycling services
by 2027. meaning councils need to ensure
curbside recycling services are provided
to all households in urban areas that is
Downs of thousand people or more
number three residential food scrap
collections by 2030 making food scrap
collections services available to all
households in in households in all urban
areas by 2030.
number four business scrap collection
ready by 2030 getting businesses ready
to separate food scraps from General
waste by 2030. you can see the MFE
timeline for these activities and that
below figure
next slide wastenet and new legislation
what these legislation changes would
mean for Wasteland our current waste
minimization and management plan aligns
with existing legislation however we do
need to incorporate what is required of
the changes from the proposed new
legislation also meaning we need to
strengthen our focus on information and
communication delivery to drive Behavior
change our kpis for Waste diversion will
be driven by these percentages that you
can see there figure C on the right side
shows the reporting timeline
foreign update
just a gentle update on Race net counts
like Keith Howell Optical District
Council has been appointed the voice in
a chair and mayor Mr Ben Bell of Gold
District Council Deputy chairman bag
meetings have not been reinstated for
wastenet and the first meeting was held
15th May 2023
reporting format has changed to wastenet
and is being presented to the waste
Advisory Group
the waste minimization education
strategy and education plans action
plans and the basement budget for 20 to
23 24 have now been completed and
approved by base net
slide
waste contracts
General update on Race contracts
contract 550 curbside collection and
transfer station services this is under
contract with Bond Contracting limited
and contracted until 30 June 2027.
class website collection Services the
upcoming activity service being planned
to start July 2024
future activities
are organic skill side collection
services to be included into a later
date with the timeline for the service
paying 29.30
we also need to look at updating
technology that we are currently using
in order to capture waste data more
accurately
contract 5 to 5279 landfill services
this is under contract with a B lime and
contacted until 9 July 2028.
its contracts continued um contract 1057
recyclables acceptance contract this is
with recycled cell and in place until 30
June 2025
contract is not currently being managed
through ways net agreement although has
provision to service all Southern
councils upcoming activity is the
curbside standardization of recyclables
by 2024 this essentially means that the
Sorting process will need to improve
recyclable material quantity quality
through the reduction of contamination
some challenges recyclables markets are
increasingly limited and constantly
changing whereby input quality of
recyclables are required new legislation
change compliance is likely to increase
the costs
health and safety wise Waste Services is
one of the 10 high-risk Industries in
New Zealand according to health and
safety regulations 2016.
Asset Management
the new rubic Estuary close landfill
environment Southland is currently
progressing a scoping document to inform
what is required to be considered in
further investigation of the New River
Estuary landfill in order to meet ICC
runanga and Es requirements a cost of
100 000 is estimated to engage an
external consultant to project manage
workshop and develop the scope of work
needed to be carried out in the next
phase of Investigations
invercargill transfer station
possibility of upgrading to a resource
recovery part to sort and transfer
recyclable materials entries procedural
waste we need to undertake an initial
business case and investigate funding
options including
MFE planning costs are estimated at 400
000.
this is how we are looking in terms of
Optics and capex for 20 23 24 with two
full-time staff
um
outside
to summarize this Slide the level of
service the solid-based activity
balances the social cultural
environmental and economic factors for
the benefits to The Wider community
Through collection of solid waste
and through providing facilities for the
Sorting collection recovery and disposal
of waste
Solid Waste activity also collaborates
with other local territorial authorities
for the coordinated delivery of waste
management and minimization in Southland
level of service continued next slide
figure D on the right side shows the
suburbs we are currently Servicing
I understand at the March Workshop
Council confirmed they do not wish to
consider extending curbside collection
services to suburbs
and areas currently unserved including
otatara however as the new proposed
legislation changes all councils in
urban areas that's more than thousand
residents must have their recycling
service in place by 2027 meaning
auditorable need to be included by 2027.
to check whether our towns meet this
threshold I have used the stats New
Zealand Geographic boundary viewer that
was provided in the MFE report improving
households Recycling and food scrap
collection published in March 2023. this
is this report is available on the MFE
website the smallest urban areas those
with between thousand and two thousand
people will be included in this
regulation for clarity
next slide
these are the estimated capex and Optics
costs for the new services and the
different options around the collection
structure
level of service continue the waste
minimization education and budget sits
within race net and has been approved by
wastenet wastenet waste minimization
education communication strategy
provides a framework for delivering
education initiatives and communication
activities across Southland to induce
Behavior change minimize waste and
increase efficiency the education
framework budget and delivery timeline
are now complete and approved by wisenet
foreign
requirements to maintain compliance
first one is standardized acceptable
recyclables by 2024. this essentially
means starting February 2024 all
councils
all Council household recycling services
must accept the same standard set of
materials some councils will need to
stop collecting some type of materials
to start collecting new ones some will
need to stop collecting liquid paper
boat foil
aerosols soft Plastics polystyrene and
Plastics three four six and seven in
their household recycling collection
these materials are problematic to sort
and recycle and often end up in the
landfill some will need to collect new
materials such as plastic number five
glass and pizza boxes councils that need
to start collecting glass will have
until 2027 to do so our costs will be
around the educational communication
campaign driving the message through to
the general public on what is required
of them to achieve this outcome Focus
will be on how we get public to rethink
waste to reduce waste at their household
levels for example leave your bins out
only if you need to putting the right
things into your recycle bin keeping
your recycling Clean and Free from
contamination reduce and prevent food
waste think twice about waste before
purchasing products Etc MFA is
developing two sets of campaigns that
councils could use figures the figure on
the right side you can see that shows
the launch timeline for these
communication
or just have a weak question is it okay
or
um we're just gonna to put for this
slide okay yeah we're just gonna do them
right at the end thanks
measuring performance these are the
proposed three levels of kpi
one is wasting it the other one is
invercargill city council long-term plan
and then you've got the invercargill
city council internal
this is how we are measuring ways
currently these are the current kpis
performance standard direction from
Ministry for the environment the new way
strategy sets a series of national
targets and goals to be achieved by
2030. I have enlisted those targets here
um or talk to it the waste diversion
Target for the effectiveness of curbside
Services is set as a 10 purpose
introduction of waste going into the bin
a 30 purpose introduction of material
going to final disposal that is going to
a landfill rather than being recycled a
30 reduction in biogenic methane
emissions from waste the standard
material list is being created and
councils are required to comply we are
still waiting on further information
there are some useful reading available
on the MFE website if you're interested
to know more
future activities we need to start
looking at these activities as we head
further down the path
we are currently working on a battery
disposal project but this is in the
initial investigation stage
next steps
we need further Direction on these items
so certainly need more information from
the ministry for the environment
yeah and thanks for listening happy to
take questions now
okay panya I'll give you first first go
yeah my question is um what's the new
changes in mind what uh around waste
that go into bins and and being disposed
of what's the items that you've actually
excluded or noticed that have now been
excluded from the booms what what's been
put in place
theme I mean you just mentioned
batteries was one
yeah
what about the other items
so it depends on what you're talking
about if you're talking about um things
that have been excluded now from with
standardization of recyclables for
example
um
so essentially that this I think is is
driven around that concept of focusing
on what you can recycle well and
actually that we have end-use markets
for rather than hoping that we can
recycle absolutely everything
um my understanding from the data that
I've seen is that the volumes of those
categories of recycling that we're no
longer collecting is is quite small that
the chunky and volumes are in those
materials ones twos and fives and the
other ones are quite small they will be
diverted to landfill as a result of that
though so they'll just go to your normal
rubbish things they they would but I
have seen stats from some of those
councils that made the change early
voluntarily and just saw the you know
the rubbish and the recycle lines didn't
change a great deal because of those
being a lower volume
okay Barry as far as a yellow bin
contamination where we're putting glass
in with cardboard and
no good for anything then
um
we've got a time span here for a glass
collection of 24 to 24. can we not speed
that up
become aware of in the last 24 hours
around the achievability of even one
July 2024 the information that we're
receiving from our contractors is that
we would actually have to order the new
Bins as at the end of this month for
that change to be possible and obviously
we've still got a period of public
consultation
Etc to go through so we are working with
our contractors around as fast as we can
make that happen but even one July 2024
we may struggle to achieve
um just jump in there there is another
option over the weekend I spoke with the
chief executive of kapiti coast
and they they've got quite an ingenious
way of doing this and sort of left field
is that they use the yellow bin
alternate Wicks one week it's standard
recycling products second week the same
bin is with glass and all it requires is
is the management of within a household
to have the appropriate product
put and then put in and now that that's
an option that we may want to consider
since it's in trial by another Council
it doesn't require buying any more bins
the I I absolutely agree that it's a
good way to go and it was what happened
when I was in Queenstown we did exactly
that what it requires though is for you
to be already doing a weekly collection
that you can then drop back to those
being fortnightly because we're already
at fortnightly then we start having to
drop even further back to monthly Etc so
it does have a much bigger impact on us
but it is one of the options that we've
put forward for consideration right so
it introduces it gets rid of the bin
purchase option but it creates another
logistic
problem Grant yeah I think it's a good
secret
um
you know there's a couple of things here
noting by 20 30 we have to have a 50
waste reduction and because of the
population size of Autotire we do have
to have a solution to click their waste
apply by 2027 yeah so it sort of answers
the decision up there around that second
one but I think it's really important
that you know we we've got to have a
strategy to reduce waste and we've got
to actually try as much as possible to
leverage off other councils as you've
just highlighted rangi but also you know
think about waste as a resource as much
as we can and what can we reuse recycled
but it falls back to what's our strategy
around waste
and we've got to nail that down and then
come up to solve the problems around if
we use two builds one one we won the
next as opposed to just trying to go
around and hit moles on the head and fix
problems without actually stepping back
and saying what's air strategy 10 15 20
years and that fills in all the sorts of
things that environment cell phone are
doing around you know because if you
look forward there's no way we continue
to
um well we you know we're probably gonna
re-look it there down there because the
water's going to come up and then we're
going to get really exposed around
what's here it is I mean look one of the
things that's come up
um with the MFE and they've suggested
that wasn't the answer to you so they're
going to make mandatory that by 2030
we've got a curbside collection for your
food scrap percent of your kitchen now
over the past month we've had
consultation with the public
and the public have strongly said well
the feedback I've had is saying
composting is very real and and you use
your food scraps to create composting
you grow your vegetables and stuff like
that now that makes Common Sense except
the MEP when I challenged them last
Monday about this they they didn't they
weren't interested they they're whacking
moles on the head they they don't
understand and
um imagine you know two-thirds of
invercargill's population wanting to
retain their food scraps and then having
to fund an expensive this involves extra
trucks picking up a bucket this big and
I mean quite hilarious actually but if
you you look in there was a thing on the
TV over the weekend about the the urban
Gardens in Christchurch and the lady and
we must go and see when we're up with
the long-term thing you know so if you
thought about the people that died use
their waste for compost and there's an
education process there maybe that we
could have local laws get you know
Community Gardens where that goes to
them and then the community
gets the shearing absolutely Aaron do
you want to comment on this or is this
something that Council needs to drive in
an Initiative for because it completely
the MFA had just got no idea on this one
I've actually
um asked for some statistics out of our
waste swap analysis that we did prior to
the last Waste Management minimization
plan just so that I can actually go back
and have a look at invercargill's makeup
of waste
um look I I possibly would tend to think
that the MFE view that people perhaps
overthink that they divert more than
they perhaps do is probably a correct
one I think we'd want to make sure that
any of our decisions going forward are
based on the data that we have in front
of us yeah but we we can we have that
data and we can go back in and do some
analysis around that
you know this is a real problem we can
solve ourselves we shouldn't be waiting
we know what we've got to get to we
shouldn't be waiting on MFE you know I
think this is a great opportunity for us
to grip this up develop a really good
strategy for our community and get on
with delivering it in a really
sustainable and successful way for a
community if we think about waste as a
resource we educate and we use
technology to make decisions I think one
of one of the things that
um
we could do better in that space is
around we haven't looked at our transfer
station I think to its or transfer
stations to their full potential in
terms of that diversion so one of the
things you will have seen that there was
an item up there around investing in
actually looking at what our transfer
stations would need to be able to move
them towards that that term that tends
to be bandied around as resource
recovery parks and whether or not we
have sufficient space to be able to do
that if it's the right location for us I
suspect we probably can find sufficient
space to do that but I think there's
absolutely more that we can be doing at
that coal face absolutely
everyone so Grant picked up on some of
what I wanted to say which was about
local solutions to this issue rather
than wait so the paracordi all those
sorts of things are we partnering well
enough are they per or is there ability
to partner I know that Aurora Gardens
those sorts of things
would they be able to use that and is
that a way and I think of that with the
glass as well I I'm really reluctant for
us to wait and I know this is the
long-term plan so I'm sort of getting a
little bit out of line but it really
bothers me that we know there's a
problem with glass collection that we
sort of keep pushing it off down the
road when we should actually be reaching
out to our community and saying what is
your solution because we don't have all
the answers but what answers we have
cost you lots more money can you come up
with a solution that is community
focused Community Driven
that meets everybody's needs it needn't
be the
you know MFE be blowed it needn't be the
big monster that we're trying to create
because I saw in the air four bins and
I'm I'm going what four bins I've only
got two now I'm going to have two more
in where my son lives in in waikato they
have a small
uh
wouldn't even be a quarter of a bin
without a lid that you put your glass in
okay
we don't have green waste you have to
pay to have green mice taken here is
that one of the bins that MFE are
talking about are we further dividing
things up and how does that get
collected what is our community appetite
for that what do we do with the green
waste if we collect it are we looking at
composting it or whatever you know it's
some of this could be driven by
Community answers rather than us as
bureaucrats sorry no no that's a fair
question I I can just provide a piece on
the community aspect that we do already
have in train there was money um in the
wastenet budget allocated well there
always has been money allocated to
community initiatives what we're doing
is just essentially refocusing that in
the same way that
um invercargill city council issues
um a call for applications for Community
funding annually we're actually going to
roll in the same with our waste funding
so that it's very visible what budget we
have there and that once a year we will
call for applications into that so that
there is the ability for there to be
Community Driven Solutions in that space
okay um Erin I need to follow on from
the question of Evelyn with the green
with the not Greenways because that's
completely different with this food
scrap collection by 2030 obviously the
mfv must have an intended place for it
to go to where it you know to be turned
into whatever now is that a something we
have to go out and tender for or the
cost of that discount to wear that or
how does this whole work because we're
actually creating under the whack-a-mole
thing we're creating a monster that
really is not needed
because you're going to have to take
this truck full of beautiful
um potato skins and stuff and and go
somewhere
and who who funds that this Council fund
that plant or do we get a private
contract or a house or work because you
can't it's good enough to have the
collection but it
so at the moment for those who've been a
little closer to it you may have seen
that there were two different timelines
around food waste collection
um the earlier timeline Annie may be
able to tell me that
2027 I think it was
um was around those local government
areas that already had a disposal for
one of a better word solution within
their region and the latter timeline
being for those that did not there is
currently funding available for us to
provide an application to to do a
business case on what our solution may
look like for Southland or
otago south and potentially
and then we expect that there may also
be funding available for some of the
capital investment in doing that but
absolutely you were right this is going
to cost councils money to deliver
probably a capital solution and then
ongoing operational costs 2030. so so
with that can I ask that just sometime
this year that it's brought back to
council this Council not necessarily
waste net what an indicative price
maybe because we looking at setting
rates and stuff and we need to know
roughly the impact per household on what
a government directive like this may
cost and so we have got some tentative
figures in the budget but as I'm sure
you can imagine we're not at all sure
yet what that solution may look like but
it we would expect it to be upward of 10
million dollars
right just to get rid of your potatoes
radio Okay Ria
just want to pop back to the um glass
collection
um
focus I at this stage I'm not I'm
interested in in you know putting
together or dying but I asked to put
together a really good um strategy of
how to cope with it I'm not totally
convinced since they're throwing up some
more bins having a vehicle collect the
bins and transport off that glass too
somewhere I'm not actually convinced at
that stage that there is our best option
and um would like
um other ideas to come forward
um I've always banged on about the fact
that uh bottle Banks would be a good
concept
here in invercargill such as they were
many many years ago and that we could
lean on a partnership with the iot to
collect all glass and beer bottles as
well
and Australia just recently they have a
scheme there for and it's called
containers for change whether it's glass
or plastic and that um yes it was
originally a cost
um to do that but it's returning
um Teen Falls in terms of how to
minimize their waste
the other option is what grants did
um that they are out there is swapping
the yellow bunny out
um for alternative
um waste products inside of those bins
too I just yeah I think that looking at
this and talking about it but still not
having a clear
Vision to move forward with kind of like
it's so I think there's in some ways
we've possibly missed a little bit of a
step in this process in that
um what a lot of other councils around
the country have done in deciding what
their direction would be for solid waste
is essentially to do a business case
process where they would look through
all of the potential different waste
streams and the different options and go
what do we want waste to look like in
Southland out 10 20 years what I guess
we're grappling with is that we're
um probably sitting a little bit behind
where some of the other councils have
gone and so I think rather
rather than in Southland or in South
London absolutely yes so um
there are um no Gore's got no recycling
is part of Southland
we're not behind Gore
I'm talking about Southland being
somewhat behind yeah yeah yeah
um so what what we what we could do is
we absolutely could go back and do that
but it means that we need to invest some
money and we would need to probably take
12 months out in doing that I think what
we've what feedback I've received um
even in previous workshops that we've
had as as well as outside of workshops
is that the rest of the country has done
this work we need to leverage the work
that the rest of the country has done
and get moving now I'm most happy to
take direction from counselors to where
they would like us to go moving forward
sustainably quickly right I've got a
list here
um we've got nobby's next
um you're being generous to say that
we're uh the tail end of the statistics
field we're we're The Worst by country
more
um so putting aside Gore that doesn't do
any Recycling and how emfe allows them
for four and a half years to do that's
just mind-boggling
um and to touch on the issue of the
glass recycling
um uh emfe again did a trial and I think
Blenheim and somewhere else might have
been kapiti about recycling bottles or
glass and you've got a refund for
whatever you put into the system and the
cost was at the front end which is a
good way of doing it but they've canned
that now shoes upon
um they just stopped it and come back to
a later stage so I mean mfp
unfortunately tends to move around quite
a bit on these issues
um so I'm not all that excited about
recycling food at this stage it's too
far off for me but
um certainly the glass one we need to do
we really need to but the other issue I
think that came up which was interesting
was the issue of the classes of plastics
that we can recycle and and that
landscape will change too because if if
and when the palletizing plant runs at
its full full way of doing it um
certainly uh MFE and the green party
have both said to me that once Macario
gets up and runs and it can take to they
can take all classes of plastic with
exception of bottle tops which are too
hard but they've got a marker for those
um that they'll start pushing those
similar sorts of plants into the likes
of Auckland with our major issues so
there could be eight nine teen plants
spin around Auckland that just chew up
all the Plastics which would be great
but the other thing I guess that's
really really frustrating for those that
weren't here last term you'll probably
know anyway that we've got the recycling
contract here and SDC it's got the uh
supplemented contouring it sits
alongside it so we still manage their
load as well which is okay
um but Gore hasn't come on board and
even though the Emir said it was a
campaign if you've had we're nine months
down the track it's just a slip of a pin
on a piece of paper and it could all be
done but it's just not
so while we sit in the wear Group which
is The Advisory Group which is at the
governance level and talk about all
these things we don't have commitment
let me just go around around the circle
so that frustrates the hell out of me
and while I'd like to see us do well our
certainly listen to the cargo now we
still get measured by the regional
result which is what Randy was saying
that you know southland's the worst
recycling region in the country and
we're not being helped by some people
um so that's a level of dysfunction that
I guess
is frustrating
[Music]
um
it'll be interesting on the issue of the
the bins going at Toyota Tara because a
lot of people
pay privately for that so they'll get
they're going to get a rate increase
which if that's fine pay for what you
what services you get
um but it's really interesting you don't
you don't see a lot of people know it's
hard doing green waste and vegetable
waste and stuff like that because the
minimum size of a 600 tire is one acre
so a lot of people do composting you've
got a little thing at the corner and do
their own thing
um I do as well it's not so easy to do
if you're on Lake them lake or in town
because food scraps for me at can be
problematic
um so it'll be interesting once we start
to implement
towards that as well I guess but we
certainly didn't need to do something
about the glass so it's just a
no-brainer all right it ruins our
recycling if it breaks up on the truck
if we put it into the other bin that
goes to landfill the weight goes up and
we pay by weight
okay we've got Grant Peter the empire
yeah I think Erin dancer your question
you know be good to see you know you've
been a you're this smell is to see an
action plan presented back to us to say
well you know what are we going to do
and how are we going to do it on a
one-pager and so just interrupt there so
we've got this is where it gets fuzzy
with wastenet Aaron where you know do we
do our own I mean I love to do our own
because we did some done yeah but
um
Howard County that is I hear your point
but how is it any different for us in
terms of what outcomes we're trying to
get around waste we're trying to be
effective around it around cost
we're trying to get the best outcomes
around some of our community well-being
sustainability pieces
I agree that those I think from a staff
perspective the high level objectives
that we're getting across the three
councils I don't think that there's a
great deal of dissimilarity in that
there is an action plan for Waste net
which um a version of that did come
through this forum I understand if
you're saying that it would be helpful
to have that as a plan on a page
um I think then that's something that
way snap can prepare which I would
expect would be helpful across all three
councils yeah
um yeah but I look I just want to look
I've been on wasting it for nine years
coming up ten now and and
and honestly it's not a fast-moving
machine and you do not get consensus so
we're trying to do our thing we we're
focused we've got our outer Tower issue
that's a separate issue we've got lots
of things we want to do and it's been
mentioned today but if we put it through
the waste net grinder it's sorry my
experience is that we are going to have
uh elected members from SDC and from
Gore telling us
basically how to do a key infrastructure
thing for this city and I don't think
here and it's going to work and the last
meeting was a good example of that Grant
yeah we got talking about glass being
important to do and it's easily done in
the city just a third bill
um but SDC weren't having a viral they
said look we've got small communities
spread around the place we're not going
to run a truck way out to wherever oh hi
nightcaps to pick up 20 glass bins
because the carbon Footprints just you
shooting yourself on the foot without it
so they they were looking at other
options not not Burns they were looking
at places that the locals could drop
their glass off and it would build up a
certain period and then it would be
taken away so there are different fixes
to the problem correct and we're getting
consensus is really hard work okay
better keep moving along Peter yeah
thank you I see the contract with a B
lime expires or comes to lean in 2028 is
five years away what happens then they
renegotiate or going to find another
place oh no no it's just just a contract
that you you hopefully roll over no we
don't want to go looking for another
hole no but that's what it says up there
I just asked the question yeah
renegotiate with them yeah do you want
to talk to that Annie or Aaron I I think
what we would be looking to to do would
be looking for the best value for
invercargill City rate payers and
presenting council with definitely one
and if there are any other options in
that space so the other option would be
the next a grade landpool would be Cape
Valley Christchurch to track it there so
I think that could probably work itself
out
um Leslie you'll note that but we've got
panya next then Leslie
I'm very supportive of the recycling of
glass and every second week in the open
that's all good but I'm not really con
um sort of
got is really what we do with our
hazardous time waste
literally I'm really sort of not clear
on how we
um dispose of it and when we're talking
household chemicals Garden chemicals
those bottles like weed killer and
things like that paint
at the moment I'm just really not clear
because at the moment we're pulling them
into the bin with the changes it's going
to change it's now going to go into our
rubbish which will end up in our
environment which is damaging so we that
was right at the last meeting yeah MFE
response was just terrible yeah and we
raised exactly the same thing what about
batteries what about e-car batteries
there's a whole raft of things and all
they said was oh yeah we're looking at
rubber tires and it's all the only thing
they tend to do and we see look we're
putting a lot of stuff that we don't
know where to put and they had no idea
today they just drew a blank really I
think in terms of
we need to you know there are only two
staff that are employed at this stage
across all of westnet
um I think the other thing to keep in
mind is that invercargill City employs
no waste stuff
um so in terms of what we can achieve we
had a look at our priorities from a
wastenet perspective we did look at
hazardous waste and we decided that
actually batteries was our first focus
and so at the moment
um the team were doing a significant
amount of work around a battery disposal
option
um and we'll bring in an update back to
wastenet and then obviously that will
come through to to council through that
Forum in terms of hazardous waste we had
pushed that into next financial year at
the moment our instruction is for people
to take leftover hazardous waste back to
the supplier that they got it from
um so are you talking household
chemicals absolutely chemicals so you're
going to take the empty retailer bottle
back to the miter 10 yeah that's right
right
at this stage so we would intend to have
a next step around potentially so
potentially having a disposal perhaps at
the various different transfer stations
around the region but that's something
that's going to come at at cost
because obviously co-locating all of
those chemicals together requires there
to be specially built bunkers and things
like that for a specialist transport
companies Etc as we all use cleaning
products
I I I'm happy for you to feed that
feedback into your waste net
Representatives that you would perhaps
like a different focus of priority
um right Leslie
thank you um Erin
let's recycling
pretty comprehensively that we had more
or less come to a consensus that
invercargill city council could move
alone on a solution for the city
that there probably was a different
solution for Southland District Council
which might involve collection points
and perhaps the same sort of thing for
Gore but I thought we had reached a
consensus that it was more a matter of
us deciding whether it's a third bin
whether it's
collection points in invercargill is an
interim measure
whether it's I I think there I I would
suggest there was a consensus around
elected members of that as well
um however that the what I took was
there was an instruction to staff to go
away and essentially develop the options
and bring that back through the
long-term plan process that's what we
are doing at the moment there's at this
stage the discussions at an officer
level are with Gore and Southland
District to also explore the potential
for that glass out bin and the cost
implications for each different Council
around doing that we're working through
that process at the moment what I would
say though is that because we would have
to
we would probably struggle to
um do the lowest cost option for
invercargill City if we were going it
alone and that's just what we are
working through at the moment yeah so
you are present you are presenting the
possible go alone for invercargill City
Council
I would probably intend to have that as
a backup option if the other councils
didn't confirm their long-term plans
because I thought we were interested
definitely in the option of as if we
can't get the full
Regional consensus that we would look
carefully at doing it ourselves
in the most cost effective way but I I
I'm just checking with other councilors
because I didn't that was my
understanding too and so from a wastenet
perspective we would need to provide
each council with that option as well
yes yeah
but in case there wasn't it doesn't pick
it up we were still interested and you
know similarly from Gore's perspective
if invercargill City and SDC didn't pick
it up what would be the implications for
them and SDC as well I'm sorry I'm
sitting here a little bit with the waste
net hat on
we'll see you're right you're right yeah
we did agree to that because yeah
because that's why it's getting confused
Gore take two bins and just throw them
both into landfill they're not going to
be any hurry to get a third man that
does exactly the same thing
so being uh being a an increased level
of service potentially
um this third bin or the Glass Service
it's definitely going to cost a wee bit
more even if we still use multi-use the
yellow bin people elected members have
brought up other options of bottle Banks
voluntary stuff and you gotta this
community focused stuff is really
interesting that you get off your ass
and you actually do it and you actually
save save money it makes sense I mean
the old days the bottle drives and stuff
like that and if each household looked
at how much actual glass they use some
probably use very little glass that is
everything's in Plastics and stuff so I
think if we can have a you know come our
ltp and out of the ltp we get a decision
by the invercargill public on what the
what the best idea is there is a
significant amount of time that goes
into our contractors pricing each of
those different options at this stage we
have our own I asked them to price a um
up to price bin based glass collections
um are we saying that we would like to
seek pricing from our Contracting
Partners around bottle Bank only options
I thought that's what we were expecting
to be back uh yes I mean I get a chair
of Finance yeah yeah well the thing to
me should be that if if we make an
investment or spend some money somewhere
that the way it should work is that
should be some saving may not be
directly a dollar for a dollar but there
should be some saving or if we took
glassy out of just putting in the other
Browns we wouldn't be paying as much for
what we have to pay
you know to put it through the gator
Brown's defense group so so there's it's
a there's some offset if we use grass
and put it down another Channel
we're taking it out of our existing
system which we pay have a cost the main
motivation behind the glass separation
is the contamination of recyclables so
that's the driver at the moment some
people are volunteers of course because
if it stays contaminated it has a cost
massive cost right so there's an offset
correct right so so we're not just
thinking about cost there's
I don't think that we would find that
this would be a purely Financial
um that this would Stack Up purely on a
financial basis no no but it
by just reflecting just the cost where
we're overeating it around if we have
the cost less what we save it becomes
less across the community oh no the
swing is around about absolutely so we
we can absolutely we can we can show you
the contamination cost next to the glass
out collection cost yeah but that can
tap we don't have I guess data at this
stage around how much of that total
contamination cost is likely to reduce
once glasses out
is not just that but if you leave them
in the the normal bins you've got the
cost that you're saving to landfill
because that's weight related yeah you
take glass out you've got less cost
right we're just about on 12 o'clock and
I'm gonna let Leslie yeah I just
interested I just want
to just want a table
where
if we could get the cost of double use
of a yellow bin
is an option
because to me that seems like an issue
that's probably well worth exploring and
we haven't got the costs now because
it's how do you store a momentum yeah
I'd be really interested in discussing
that's the first I've ever heard of that
being an option
um it would be something we'd need to
explore I would I I would certainly be
interested in exploring it yeah
that couldn't that could happen
reasonably quickly it does also a little
bit fly in the and absolutely we'll go
and have a look at it but just be aware
it also flies a little bit in the face
of that very clear coloring and
allocation around different types of
bins being used for different purposes
but it I think it's probably worth
exploring if we're looking at it all the
options for what we could do as quickly
as possible it's working in cavity
it's just education isn't it
you've seen the photographs recently and
what happens when we get the wrong sort
of stuff in the in the recycling that
was just oh that's it was horrible
and so you've only got to get
10 of your population not understanding
what week we're in and you've got to
miss right on the closing note sorry
just as a closing point from staff can
we just have some direction around
bottle Banks is that something that
staff are being sought to provide
pricing I think so that's voluntary yeah
hey it's a good start so the bottle Bank
yes
sorry
it's got to be mindful that if we do
all Alternatives then you
but you've got to do the alternative
you've got to have bottle Banks or
nothing you can't have bottle Banks and
a blue bin that people are going to be
charged for because they'll say look I'm
not putting anything to my blue bin I'm
just running it down to the local shop
and putting it in the thing so it's got
to be an alternative but not a part
solution but that's the whole point of
us investigating let's look at which
options are best sustainability we don't
have that costs in front of us so Aaron
the answer is yes
um strategically placed I think it's him
to Maria's Point we've actually got to
step back a bit further and access
invest some money in understanding what
a hot a greater solution looks like in
bottlenecks yeah exactly because
otherwise we're just going to run around
spend some money doing this and it might
it might not work or we can't execute it
or it doesn't fit in with what wasted
want to achieve and we're just going to
keep going round and round step back
further
and understand what we're trying to
solve for here
and and then how weaken them I mean
things within air jurisdiction
in what might get solved if waste net
step up or step out I think I think
Aaron if you got a sort of an indication
now on the
no I'm not I'm sorry actually I don't
um what I guess I'm questioning is
uh are you asking Grant your elected
members who are on wastenet to go back
and Advocate at waste net for this piece
of work to be done regionally are you
asking invercargill City staff to
self-fund yes a piece of work and
therefore that will need to be done with
external
um assistance and then budget put aside
for that yep yeah well I I think I'll
tell you what we'll do because
um
which means we're not going to implement
anything in
particularly quickly because we're going
to spend some time researching what the
right thing is to do look I think just
quickly because we've got other topics
to carry on here we
live we've got time next Tuesday we can
carry on this discussion
um in the infrastructure meeting I'm
sure as uh as a late item in public we
can just narrow it down a bit more
people can never think about it because
we're just going around the circles a
wee bit here and so
um but I think the only way we're going
to get it done is probably through ICC
but I hate the thought Erin of using
Consultants to in you know Thirty forty
thousand dollars to get a report on
bottle Banks we had a we hit a boat we
know yeah so anyway look we're going to
end that conversation now and we'll
carry on
unless there's anything more in the
report
essentially staff are just looking for
some clear Direction okay can that be at
that type of beer editorial resources
you know yes because that's actually a
really good one yep yeah absolutely
we'll never know another guy at this on
Tuesday
is there a paper being sought from staff
on that I think we just if we can
continue the line of thought and we can
narrow it down I mean Leslie's face some
good points on where we've already been
and I think we if we can just finalize
it we're just the only reason I'm
stopping it now is because we don't have
time just a quick quick can I just say
very quickly that Barry's just raised a
good point lots of
and then the cargo still have that small
button yep I don't know it could be it
could be re-emerging as a possible part
of a glass solution if we went the
bottle back way that could be where you
collected Your Glass to put to take to
the bottle
lots of invercargill people have still
got that small bun
I don't think we need to consultant to
get some basic figures if you worked on
having a bottle bank somewhere which is
a big skip with a spell on the top you
might want one for every thousand or
twelve hundred people in the city so
you're going to need whatever that works
out to be
um any 40 50 or 60 or 70 of them spin
around the city
um how hard would it be to locate them
what would the cost be to provide the
bin the big bins and what would the
collection be what's a fortnight or once
a once a month maybe even just pick them
up okay right I can do that myself I
have a we have a chat about this next
Tuesday thank you thanks Aaron
um
this afternoon it is this afternoon
um living challenge who's who's a part
of my team he's the uh asset manager for
property been with Council for a short
time he's going to lead us through some
of these slides so I thought it was a
great opportunity for him to come and
have this conversation and these are
about
um this is like our other plans starting
to develop what we need to have in our
asset management plan
I'll leave it over to Vivint and I'll
jump in when he um need some help
welcome
thank you Kira
um this presentation is uh about Parks
Community buildings and public toilets
whoops
okay we act as the owner of the property
to manage the
to manage public facilities for
invercargill residents and visitors
however the activities itself they're
managed by the activity managers of the
respective areas
this is an overview of our priorities
Community outcomes we've highlighted the
key challenges we will cover on this
presentation
so this is one of our standard slides
about
highlights the level of operational
expenditure and our our capex one of the
things in this slide is a little bit
more confusing because a number of our
buildings sit within the project
management office in the in the roadmap
so some of the numbers get merged
together in this area so it's just a wee
bit um
merged up to be fair so
maintaining levels of service we've
managed the compliance requirements
pretty well with coordinate well with
the activity managers to work with them
to manage any outstanding issues
uh as a part of our three early updates
we've completed the uh asset condition
Assessments in 2022
the prints were just no sorry on this
phone yeah
I think what we what we're saying here
is that we've Meeting those compliance
levels and I think that's a really
important thing so the building wire and
fitness is one of those measures where
you actually need to get out there and
do Regal things to your buildings
um the ACM is the asbestos inspections
that are undertaken and the earthquake
prone building so our buildings have
um we've undertaken quite a bit of work
in that space to actually make sure that
they meet those requirements and I know
that through the last um ltp process
there was concerned about not having
information on a condition assessment so
we haven't completed the condition
assessments across all of our buildings
for at a component level and but to be
fair the condition assessments give us
information it doesn't actually tell you
all the answers so I guess mentionally
um Levin was involved with those direct
competition assessments so he actually
has quite a lot of background and
knowledge in what they are and how we
can use them and I guess one of our
challenges are is that to understand
where we want to be in terms of our
asset plan and our maturity and that's
something that we'll just come on to
yep the next slide is about Asset
Management maturity Asset Management
maturity is a measure of being able to
meet a current and future needs
and the lead indicator for and it does
the lead indicator for our future
performance
um the idea is to reduce the gap between
the current and Target levels here
so so in fact so
it's like the whole scale for everybody
and and you can be anywhere on that
Continuum and I guess the challenge for
each organization and each department is
how far along there is the further you
are to the right obviously the I guess
the more defined reliable and
informative your plans are so at the
moment we see we're sitting about core
which often in a property sense is a
good place to be but we do want to
continue to move over to the right that
would give you greater surety that we
have a stronger understanding of a
building and would be better at
predicting what our future demands and
needs are and across the bottom are some
of those areas where we actually see
things that you've got to do to actually
evaluate and consider on and it's so
it's just not actually saying we've got
a building and it's got a location it's
actually understanding its condition
what risks it brings
um
how can you explain what demands are
coming out of it yeah I'm going forward
with uh taking on buildings like new
Museum uh we've got to be better
equipped with all the technology so
we've really got to get to
the um somewhere between closer to the
advanced level of maturity
we've ticked off these we've done well
with the compliance requirements
um we don't compromise on these
um
other than the regulatory obligations we
stay vigilant to any safety demographic
and other well-being requirements as
well
we go beyond the regulatory requirements
by making the building safer and also
looking at Greener options to reduce
in our attempt to reduce a carbon
footprint
as a part of improving Asset Management
maturity we need to look at having a
good asset management information system
that's what we're striving towards
going forward this will help us improve
efficiency by effectively minimizing
double handling
a good example would be to have a life
condition assessment rather than having
it done every three years so we if we've
got a system that we can feed it into
directly we've always we always have the
information we need at hand
um we need to revisit uh some of the
underutilized utilities and formulate a
plan and if I identify a purpose for
them
and I guess what what woman's getting at
there is that we have quite a range of
buildings from you know Civic Theaters
right through to some of the buildings
there parks
colleague ever news
understanding where they fit in their
organization which ones do we invest in
which ones do we focus on
is actually the challenge that we face
because having too many buildings often
brings too much cost so it's actually
just trying to make sure that each of
the building has a purpose has a future
so we understand how we can actually
manage those in a in a in a meaningful
way going forward
measuring performance
um levels of service and kpas the
property team has a part of our
deliverables provides support with
specialist services to manage properties
assets and let activity managers focus
on what they do best their core
activities
our deliverables are mainly indirect and
qualitative with a few quantitative ones
which Charming here
which we could just talk about the kpi
so lots of those kpis are actually what
the activity managers will will deliver
so I guess it's things that we set
across our operations team and our asset
team and trying to establish really good
case strong kpis going forward is
something that we'll continue to work on
so that we can I guess measure how we're
doing and that's I think something we
just need some more work on but it's
just trying to understand exactly what
everybody needs
these are the current roadmap projects
handled by the pmo
we will be
once completed it will be in a part of
our portfolio
the overview of our portfolio
um
I'm using rugby park and the cable
handled by the pmo at this point in time
and the housing public toilets
investment properties will be covered in
another presentation so we're going to
mainly focus on these
okay
so what we're talking about there is
over the next period of time that's
where our key focus is going to be
Beyond being the being I guess the
really the the important core of our
building stock we hold
um just want to interrupt there the
Civic Administration Building
that sits under the pmo roadmap
um we've had meetings with the activity
managers and we've had discussions and
we've picked up
some of the
big items
um I'm not sure do we want to go through
the list individually or we've we've
further highlighted particular ones at
the end that we can discuss on further
but I guess what we're trying to what
we're trying to understand is for those
activities to operate in those areas one
of the key things that we need to make
sure are included in our plan for
um the three years for the ltp and the
10-year and the 30-year long term so
we're trying to pick up all of the the
needs of those areas and make sure that
they're well highlighted and plan for
what happens
so I've got a few on Splash Palace Civic
Theater as well
so Splash Palace is probably a really
good example of one where the building's
30 plus years old and we are continuing
to look really closely at what the roof
does obviously when the roof needs
replaced it's not going to be an easy
job it needs to be well programmed well
planned and understood how you do that
so that's not something you can just pop
along one year and say let's replace the
roof it's actually a really difficult
piece of work to be done it has to be
coordinated
with the
um team at the pool
we've got
the Scottish theater we've got a more
detailed discussion on the Scottish
theater in the next slide so I'll leave
it for that at the moment
so with that increasing Reliance on
technology we really have to look at the
asset management information systems on
a priority
um
you need to get the speedo with our
asset management maturity
especially with the museum coming on
board and some of the other newer
buildings that will be technology
intensive so we'll pretty much have to
be ready for that
and that does a line with the um the
business Improvement project that
council's got focused on so that's
really saying is how do we actually put
all our information in one place and be
able to use it really cleverly many
times over a long time but that is also
quite a challenge in terms of our team
to make sure but as you can imagine the
museum and some of those developments
will be really highly
I guess have lots of technology that
we'll have to understand really well and
when you see some of the systems they
are and just about in 3D so there's a
whole lot of that technological
advancement we need to have to be able
to ensure that those buildings are able
to be maintained going forward because
they will need
some love when you say the museum you're
also including the Tisbury storage
facility the museum is just a I guess
symptomatic of one of the new technology
buildings that we'll have
foreign
portfolios in our budget
um
so I guess what we were trying to show
in the previous slide was really just
it's really just the order of um
numbers that we're anticipating
I think as we actually get more and more
into our buildings we will we will
understand some of their demands more
but it's showing the sorts of numbers
that are needed to invest
um as an ongoing to have those buildings
as
um part of our Council and how do we and
and maintain them over the period of
time
right and then insights oh because one
more one more one more questions so
these are the options these are further
drilling down from the previous slides
we've picked up five uh
big issues that we can talk about we've
got the Winter Garden
it's got the roof at the splash Palace
um
the roof at the splash palaces
given its size and given its type we we
could go for a like for like it's the
current one is served as 30 years and
done well
uh it's showing signs of failure now but
it can go with us like for like
replacement but it's a good opportunity
to have a look at what's available in
the market and
probably an upgrade or we might end up
with the same like for like replacement
if that's the best one but it is it's an
opportunity to look at things and also
given the uh other development phases
with the splash panels
we've got a similar thing with the uh
Library roof
there's a barrel roof which has been a
high maintenance one so we can look at
either a like for like or preferably uh
something new to go in place so we've
got less glare economics is handled
better and things like that
with the Civic Theater and Scottish Hall
they are Heritage buildings so they have
a whole new different set of
requirements
um
something that's come up with the
Heritage building is the conservation
management plan that needs to be in
place
so it look it needs to be looked at as
entire project and managed within those
Frameworks
highlighting here is that
the level investment you want like for
instance I think
when you attack this when we take the
splash Palace roof it would be good
sense to make sure we understood whether
there were some beta use could you put
more insulation on it or is the actual
whole roof structure actually fine at
the moment with what we're doing so can
we actually get a more efficient
building going forward you know as you
know 30 years on it's highly unlikely
that what we did 30 years ago is best
practice now so it's I guess that's a
challenge and we're highlighting there
is a range of numbers about how much
investment because you could go for
something that's relatively like for
like or you could really really truly
step up into a whole new era but that's
bring some dollars so finding that
finding that balance is I think the
thing that we'll work across the next
few years as we develop those skills and
actually work through but we've tried to
highlight the big key issues that are
that are out there and and the level of
investment that we're looking at and
clearly like for instance the Winter
Gardens at Queen's Park has quite an
impact
um whether you're just going like for
like or do you actually you know step up
into a different different I guess
bigger beta but I think there is
actually a case to that we have to
develop to actually explain how that
would actually work with the products
team so
okay
right we have questions
um if uh Trish
then Evelyn so yeah
are these do you need to prioritize
these or are they all needed to be done
like are they parallel or one first
we've got a range of these over over the
um the three and ten year period so it's
really trying to map some of those Works
to be done at the right time where we
can afford it and they need to be done
so
the initial steps of all of these is to
actually assess how urgent it is a good
example would have been Splash Palace
has had some short-term repairs done
where we've been out of luck had to do
some short-term repairs that will hold
it for a period of time and that has
helped us reassess when that renewal
would be from two years away to three or
four years away so we're still working
through that and that is a a bit moving
but that's what our plan looks to
actually try to produce for the ltp
Evelyn
so the notable of mission
from my perspective
is the parts office building
I don't see it there I'm not sure if
that's because Parks team themselves are
being quite
um
unassuming and not pushing something but
from a health and safety point of view I
would have thought that the parks office
building needed some attention so it's
not there
um I've been in there
I find it less than
[Music]
um
I'm actually disappointed that we have a
number of Staff working out of what as a
cobbled together series of of spaces and
I wonder
when
if this is three and ten years when we
would be planning to look at it because
I would have thought it should have been
done
some time ago
you raise a really good question and and
Parks have a wide range of structures
and buildings
at the moment we've assessed its
condition and really we can continue to
operate the building from our
perspective whether it's fit for purpose
for the activity that they deliver
outside of it but if we can hold the
building shell together that's where the
the overlap between our activity and
theirs is
um whether that's the best location
whether it's the best use of buildings
is I think is a an ongoing but that's
not necessary that hasn't been one of
the buildings that we've highlighted and
it certainly hasn't been our top
priority at the moment but we can
readdress that is it because it's not a
public use facility it's a a staff use
facility and I don't mean to demean how
staff look at things I mean we've got
um there was reference to The Cheeky
llama for example which is a public
access building
um all the ones that I see there are
Public Access buildings and are we
tending to prioritize those when we're
looking at refurbs and all that sort of
thing and I guess that's the challenge
that we've faced with this with the
administration building here and or
others about where do we place it in in
that priority list but I guess we've
tried to focus on some of our bigger
like you said bigger structures and
they're more demanding but whereas the
parks administrative area
from our condition
the the building structure itself is
intact whether it's
ideal for the fit for purpose and there
the way they deliver within that
structure is a slightly different
question
thank you but a really good one okay
knobby and then Barry uh just two quick
recent
um just wanted to clarify this building
has a
um a building warrant of fitness
I will have to check that it should it
does because the original the original
uh slide you hit up there said at this
stage we have 100 building yes foreign
so Mr chair that's about
um you have a range of requirements for
whatever systems you have in your
building and that's actually like a
frequency check so we've got emergency
lighting so we check means of egress
we're checking those are the that's what
a build and we're in Fitness really
relates to the compliance related issues
sure
um and and all of the those you know
really the important the places where
you have bigger crowd bigger number of
people are the key things that we um
have maintained sure and the other issue
is the issue of earthquake Prime
Building status
um so are all our buildings
um are they all been assessed that's one
issue and the second issue is given that
we started about our life five six seven
years ago on
a map that we had with the CBD
which
um said that Council also has a role
beyond what it does for its own
buildings but it has a role towards how
it looks at other buildings as well as
the regulator so how far are we through
that CBD issue and and our are our own
buildings okay
can I answer the second one first secret
the second part is that's actually a
regulatory function which I'm sure
Jonathan will be able to be able to help
us through there so that's actually how
we deal with those in terms of our our
existing Council buildings
I would say we've done the majority of
our bigger buildings and they do have
a range of earthquake ratings and over
time we will need to confirm what those
ratings are so obviously
um we're everyone's presumably
reasonably familiar with the the less
than 34 and the 67 and and the 100 so I
guess it's actually saying not every
building has to be 100 of the new
building code
the new building standard and like it's
actually trying to trying to address how
those which building needs what level so
that we can a continue to manage those
buildings within that envelope and
um and what is the time frame to
actually make that building compliant or
sorry meet the level that that Council
will set like this is probably the key
thing
yeah why I ask it I guess is that
um
sometimes we get some accusations that
we might be able to the private sector
putting the heat on them too
go through the process which is you know
two years to get an engineering status
report and then you get assessed and in
fact we may not have done that with our
own buildings or buildings that we lease
we've done I think just about all of our
buildings in the bigger buildings
including we've assessed some of our
treatment plant structures and those
sorts of things so we've had quite an
extensive and expensive program to
actually go through and assess those
which
um part of that is that sometimes those
standards continue to develop and evolve
and change so what the uh
against the assessment was five or six
years ago is now different as they've
learned more so often you have one then
you have to go back and have a refresh
of it because of
um it's been further defined or you know
kaikoura and those sorts of things
continue to
assist in understanding the performance
of earthquakes and buildings
thank you okay Barry yeah just in
relation to the uh xrsa Hall over here I
noticed it's got a brand new roof on it
um
I know that there's only one a lot of
people that use that haul at any one
time ever indoor indoor bowlers
and it and that's not very often either
so
wouldn't wouldn't we've been better to
put that money of that route because I'm
sure it cost a lot of money to put that
roof on
Council sold the buildings some
five six seven years ago to a private
individual so we know we're no longer we
no longer yeah so therefore it's a
private decision
Grant
yeah a couple of things
your reference back couple of pages
about your asset management system and
you're wanting to invest in one platform
and we had a discussion at
infrastructure I think last meeting
around making sure we've got technology
and using data to be able to
um
make informed decisions versus just
going with the fleet depreciation rate
and renewals program you know so does
the system you're thinking about for
this Encompass a wider
view of some of our other assets or is
it just a pure property Asset Management
no the waiter it's a what it could be
anything so can I can I add on to that a
little bit is that
um currently council's assets as a whole
sits on a number of platforms so but
moving to one but part of that the
business Improvement program which
Patricia will be
um wanting to wait to talk about shortly
um is
needs to fit under that Suite so as
um whatever happens to the three Waters
at the moment we do our property under
our IPS system which the three Waters
going forward what that will be it needs
to be a one platform which actually has
that ability to do that most of our
depreciation and our valuations done
outside our our asset systems at the
moment because none of those systems are
particularly good but the future says if
you don't have them all in one place you
can't keep your data you can't actually
make good meaningful long-term decisions
about it so so that'll be in place for
our next financial year
Financial Decay I did to say
just with respect to this um
will that mean that staff will get the
training to support the use of that yeah
yeah that would have to be parallel
really
over there the hospital past Patricia it
was a hospital it's not a hospital past
so we have got it within our program in
the business enhancement program it
isn't a easy fix to put in the new asset
management system it is a multiple year
Journey that will include training
change of process and a lot of things
that's just where we fit it within the
program as we pretty much change nearly
every system Council currently operates
under yeah but it's a worthy investment
because the better sooner we can make
informed decisions the better
Mr G one of the things that you might
have heard of as a product is what they
call Bim
it's like a three-dimensional
um there's some some organizations that
have done it from the beginning to the
end of the even the design phase like
for the museum and places so it's a
completely digital platform that has you
store everything in it so you can click
and move around and do it it's it's
really excellent it's an absolutely
intriguing technology
it's mind-numbing how much effort you've
got to put in to make it Go and Keep it
going so you should you know sometimes
hoping for those things
um
can bring pain on the way so but that's
where the technology of the future is so
just think about what we can actually do
now with our technology you have another
question with respect to how we account
for depression
Splash pillows
in charging user pays so we are we do
does the cost to use also include the
depreciation for the things like roots
or are we seeing that aside from how we
charge
um I have to take a pass on that one but
we'll discuss it next week when we bring
back Aquatics
um because that will say I'm pretty sure
it will not be included
that was sort of considered to be the
general rates impact was to provide the
building the activity within it is cost
recovery
Russell that's it any further questions
before we break the lunch
well thank you guys that's appreciate
that
and what's coming back again sorry
Patricia
you said you're bringing something back
next week has Aquatics Aquatics and I'll
bring that back
not if she is
thank you it's time for lunch you can
stop streaming now thank you